foreign
people let's just get this out of the
way okay now I know this isn't a very
comfortable subject for many of you
but I gotta say it
we have to talk about your fungus
problem okay now it's okay
don't be embarrassed you know who you
are but we can work this out we'll get
it through it together
Now call them fungi fungi fungi you
decide
but what I'd like to impress upon you is
this is a new world we need to begin
exploring
and I think we can do it in interesting
ways but all of us have had an issue
with fungi at some point in our lives
right maybe even even now we think of
fungi we think of that fuzzy stuff
that's growing on our yogurt that we
forgot in the back of the fridge right
or maybe that itch you developed by
wearing that favorite pair of pants but
just got a little bit too tight
or you know maybe you think of death and
Decay and disease when you think about
fungi
but fungi yeah maybe some of them have a
dark side I mean who of us doesn't
but I'd like to invite you to see these
un under misunderstood creatures in a
new light and maybe start to appreciate
some of the ways some of the positive
ways and inspirational ways that they
behave
so if that mold is Breaking Bad on that
yogurt that you forgot in the back of
the fridge again
right maybe it's not just rotting and
spoiling but maybe it's taking an act of
transformation of renewal and of new
possibilities
and it's that very Act
of transformation that's both so Central
to life on our planet has been important
for our own history
and maybe for the future if we can learn
from fungi we might be able to transform
ourselves and our Societies in ways that
are in Greater harmony with nature
now what do I mean when I say A fungi
have been important to our past
I'm not talking about that amazing
mushroom trip that you took back in
University
though that was probably pretty awesome
in its own right
what I'm talking about is the way that
fungi have been Central to the evolution
of life on the planet
that virtually all of life has a fungal
backstory
now think fungi I've been on the planet
for a billion years a billion years or
more
and during that time you know life was
just the the Earth was just a rocky
desolate place there was a lot of life
on it
now algae would actually escape the
waters and come onto land to evolve into
land plants but only by partnering with
fungi first as its root system
soils would begin to form as fungi ate
Rock and break down to make the
nutrients available
so you had this opportunity for New Life
to spring up
and as a result evolution of plants
would explode across the planet
which would oxygenate the atom
atmosphere
and allow the evolution of more complex
life forms like us humans
right
so this ability being on the planet for
a billion years fungi have developed all
sorts of Life Strategies to be adaptive
and diverse and resilient
I mean think about it that they survived
a billion years through great swings and
climate over hundreds of millions of
years lived through all the five Great
mass extinction events
where the dinosaurs went extinct and the
poor little tribalites and countless
other forms of life that we don't even
know that existed
but fungi persisted and thrived and due
to this day
and I think that's what drove them to me
I mean who doesn't it's so endearing
like I mean who doesn't love a good
survival story
I know I do
but fungi weren't my first love that was
music actually
and actually when I was a young young
boy I was really into Grunge music and I
played in a grunge band
and we were awful
but I didn't know that at the time and
anyhow I had to follow my passion so I
put everything in my pickup truck and I
moved from my childhood home of Kansas
City to Seattle the mecca of Grunge
music in the 90s and I was going to
start a new band
and unfortunately none of none of the
talents of Nirvana or Soundgarden rubbed
off on me
would have been a quite different life
had it did
but the Splendor of the Pacific
Northwest forest really did
and it was the trees and all the life
above ground that Drew me there but it
was the fungi and the microbes below
ground that kept me coming back
right I just got even more and more
interested about the way that they lived
all these bizarre forms the fact that
fungi are literally everywhere right now
they're on your skin in your gut
With Every Breath You Take you inhale
dozens of fungal spores every move you
make you trample mushrooms and molds
beneath your feet in the soil
and their ubiquity
is a big reason why we know so little
about fungi despite all the tools we
have at our disposal scientific tools
we know perhaps five percent of all the
fungi some three million species that
are thought to exist on the world in the
world today
now that's a massive amount of
biodiversity that we know virtually
nothing about how it lives and what it
does
and that's what really inspired me to
continue to study about fungi
and ask deeper questions could some of
this biodiversity help in creating a
more resilient future
right what could we actually learn from
fungi were there metaphors that we might
to apply to how we live
to create a more resilient future
together
I'd like to share with you some of them
some of those metaphors
the first is that fungi are
bio-intelligent
now being on the planet for so long
fungi have created a really great
ability to be good at resource
efficiency and resilience
and as it turns out spatial planning
so researchers in Japan did this super
cool experiment where they laid out they
wanted to see if fungi could help
Engineers to create more efficient
transport Networks
so they laid out oatmeal on a petri dish
corresponding to the cities of the Tokyo
metropolitan area
and they introduced the slime mold a
type of fungus whose favorite is food
ever is oatmeal and the fungus rapidly
went through a process of
self-optimization to find the most
efficient links between its favorites
ever food source
represented by a map of the Tokyo
metropolitan area
and in a matter of hours it would
recreate largely the existing railway
map of the Tokyo metropolitan area
a process that took Engineers decades to
actually produce
now the fungus it has no brain
it has no plan it was given no
instructions or guidance
but still it created a highly optimized
Network
and this convinced me and other
scientists that maybe fungi could have
practical applications to help solve
some of our human challenges in ways
that are quick
and efficient and perhaps even more
imaginative than we could do with all of
our brains put together
foreign
now another way that fungi are can
produce a metaphor is being
collaborative
now this is more most evidence in their
relationships with plants
now remember how algae evolved into
plants through the help of fungi in its
root system
well that love affair never ended
still today 90 of all land plants need
to have a mycorrhizal Association this
is the plant fungus root Association
so depicted here in this highly
realistic view of the the underground of
a forest ecosystem
you can see the fungus which exists in
most of its life as thin filaments and
the network of thin filaments we call it
mycelium
and the mycelium of the fungus can tap
into the root of plants and make a
symbiosis
and by there they exchange nutrients
that the other one isn't so good at
making or capturing so the case of fungi
they're providing minerals to the plant
to the plants and the case of the plants
through photosynthesis they're plotting
they're providing carbon
and so this exchange can go on between
the organisms but it doesn't stop there
because the fungi can tap into other
plants at the same time and other plants
can have also other fungal partners
so what you end up is this massive
underground Network mediated by fungi
now it's not just nutrients that are
flowing
but also communication because plants
can talk to each other through the
fungal Network to create to for perhaps
to chemical signals to be able to warn a
pest attack for example
now fungi are also regenerative
now their ability to decompose
is important for the planet to say the
least because fungi eat death
and give it back to life as nutrients to
start the cycle anew in nature there's
no such thing as waste I mean waste is a
human concept
everything is used everything is
circular
everything becomes something else
and if you don't appreciate fungi you
will for one reason and it's that
decompositional ability I mean think
about it we would be buried under
kilometers deep of undecayed plant
matter and dead animals and poo
without the decompositional ability of
fungi and that would be a pretty crappy
existence you gotta admit
so it's a metaphor fungi can provide us
with ways of being biointelligent
collaborative and resilient
but I also believe that fungi have
practical implications in how we produce
materials
and this is actually my very cool day
job as researcher at a fermentation
science company here in Oslo that's
reimagining a new world of materials
more sustainable materials of everyday
products
so let me give you some examples
so one is biomaterials so taking a
fungus we can literally grow new
materials using agricultural residues to
replace unsustainable products like
Styrofoam or rock wool that often end up
in landfills or in pollution
so we can grow things like soundproofing
panels or insulation to buildings
or we can make
mushroom frisbees like the possibility
is nearly endless
we can also make textiles from fungi so
for example animal-free leathers
so normally I mean usually you have a
cow and it takes about three years to
make a leather and all the resources and
animal death
that is involved not a great way to make
leather if you could make it another way
like with fungi it takes days to make it
using fungi's
much better way that's both efficient
and ethical in how we can make Leathers
of the future
and then there's food a subject I'm
particularly passionate about
now with fungi we can make a whole range
of sustainable and delicious foods from
fungi things like meat replacements for
seafood
or dairy for example or even a new class
of food that doesn't look like any of
that stuff
possibilities are Unlimited
and we can do it in a way that is a
fraction of the environment footprint
now fungi are self-replicating organisms
so we can make it in really huge
quantities and help address the
challenge of how we're going to make
more food and lower our impact on the
planet it's a big challenge
we can do it with fungi
and last but not least fish feed I mean
here we are in Norway right
the world's largest producer of salmon
and what do we feed that salmon as
proteins two things primarily soy and
fish meal neither of which are
sustainable sources of protein for the
future because they contribute to
overfishing in the oceans and land use
patterns that degrade forcing of the
lands
so we need to come up with more
sustainable sources and how we feed our
fish
and what if we could do it using fungi
to create the proteins to feed those
fish and we could do it in a way that we
were using byproducts of of Food
Industries as food for our fungus when
we grew it
would be an amazingly sustainable system
and dare I say it would help in our
self-sufficiency
now one of the coolest things about
being a fungal researcher is with all
that diversity out there probably the
coolest thing that fungi can do we
haven't even uncovered yet
the most amazing fungal discoveries are
still waiting to be made
they were only scratching the surface of
what we might be able to achieve with
the help of fungi
so I have a hope
and my hope is that we transfer our
fungal problems into fungal Solutions
right that we look to the fungal world
for new mindsets and new metaphors and
even new materials
as we think more collaboratively
regeneratively and with more
bio-intelligence as we approach the
future
just like fungi
thank you very much
[Applause]